the sun belly up over birmingham
wholesale market
and hundreds of crates of goods have
already passed in and out
traders here rely on a near constant
flow of lorries
for some up to eighty percent of supply
comes from the eu
for all tomorrow means new procedures
and potentially problems
the pandemics already left businesses
like peter's up to 40
down there's going to be an impact as in
there's going to be a cost involved and
obviously that unfortunately that cost
is going to be handed on
to the consumer because obviously with
the extra paperwork
and the extra time at the ports i did
vote for brexit
but i think if i had my time again i
don't know
i really are serious with that yeah yeah
positive impact on your business
yeah but there's optimism here too
steven's a fifth generation fish trader
and says any problems are small fry
short term there may be
a couple of weeks where suppliers are
maybe just a little bit nervous
but long term i'm very optimistic i
believe it's a huge opportunity
for this country as a whole i really do
many traders here have been in this
business
for decades but few were even of working
age when britain first joined the common
market back in the early 70s
for better or for worse whether welcomed
or feared
january the first heralds an entirely
new era for british business
although most goods won't face new
tariffs or quotas there will be customs
checks on anything crossing between the
eu and the uk
some goods including some uk animal food
products will have to comply with new
rules and restrictions
julia's will need new kent access
permits to enter the county
and some automatic workers rights will
be curtailed
it's all likely to cost time and money
lori's moved smoothly through dover
today
but many fear the mass cues seen in
december
essex-based haulage firm youngs are so
concerned they're temporarily halting
all european services
the dangers of being involved in long
long delays and receiving no revenue for
those long days is actually
would actually cost more money it is a
gamble on our part we might have an
awful lot of egg all over our face
come next week but i suspect not i think
it's going to be a very
very challenging week next week many
others must also meet a whole new set of
standards to sell to the eu
renee's small business makes science
kits for children
she estimates new safety certifications
alone will cost her 20 000 pounds
i'm really worried that there's going to
come a point where
cash flow is going to become a real
issue
i might not be able to afford to pay my
team
um and the stress and the mental load of
that
is by far outweighs anything else so
i'm really worried about the impact the
financial impact the real
tangible financial impact this is not
possibly about the impact of what of
brexit and the possibilities this is
about right now
small businesses really struggling to be
able to
keep going financially
brexiteers have promised a new era of
opportunity for business
adjusting to it may not be without its
casualties helen ann smith sky news
birmingham